en tant que candidat à l'élection
présidentielle emmanuel macron
rebondissant certainement sur les
déboires de son rival françois fillon
avait promis moralisation de la vie
publique
fini l'ancien monde et ses arrangements
la limite de la légalité place un nom
nouveau fait de transparence et
d'exemplarité
ça c'était donc en 2017 et si depuis des
mesures ont été prises en ce sens il
semblerait que cet élan s'arrête aux
portes de l'elysée et de matignon
une chercheuse membre du think tank
l'observatoire de l'éthique publique
ainsi tenter d'obtenir les fiches de
paie du président de la république et de
son premier ministre
pas de scoop en vue puisque leur
rémunération et public environ 15000
euros brut par mois pour le locataire de
l'elysée par exemple ce qui intéresse
est chercheuse s'est en réalité de voir
comment s'articulent les différentes
indemnités prévues pour le président
depuis les réformes menées en 2007 et
c'est donc assez confiante que lucy
punch et de contacter les services de
l'elysée mais ceux ci refusent
s'appuyant sur une note de la cades à la
commission d'accès aux documents
administratifs datant de 2009 et qui
exclut le président de la république
d'une quelconque obligation en la
matière l'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter
là mais la chercheuse lui six mondes
shadow fait preuve de pugnacité en
décembre 2020 elle interroge à nouveau
la cada la commission donne alors un
avis bien différent de celui publié dix
ans plus tôt estime dorénavant que les
fiches de paie du président sont
communicables à n'importe quel citoyen
qui en ont fait la demande sous réserve
d'une protection de sa vie privée
se réfugiant jadis derrière l'avis de
cette commission l'elysée décidé cette
fois de s'en détourner et refuse à
nouveau de publier les documents du côté
du palais présidentiel on explique que
la rémunération et en public
la communication des fiches de paie n'a
pas d'intérêt on peut regretter que la
présidence de la république ne se montre
pas exemplaire et donnent le sentiment
de se dérober à la démarche de
transparence qui s'est déployé ces
dernières années il n'y a pas qu'à
l'elysée que cet exercice de
transparence et délicats comme le révèle
cet article du monde la mairie de paris
ait frappé aussi par la réticence de
certains élus après les municipales les
163 conseillers s'étaient engagés à
rendre publique
leurs déclarations d'intérêts mais
aujourd'hui une quarantaine d'entre eux
s'y refuse toujours et que ce soit à
droite ou à gauche certains élus ne
veulent pas entendre parler de cet
exercice de transparence
de quoi renforcer la défiance des
citoyens pour leurs élus et surtout une
nouvelle preuve de la pertinence de ce
célèbre adage les promesses n'engagent
que ceux qui les écoutent